desde la capital ucraniana nuestro
compañero de france 24 en francés clovis
casal y con los detalles
todos los civiles que se encuentren en
las calles después de las 5 de la tarde
pueden ser considerados como lo que
llaman saboteadores agentes rusos
paracaidistas agentes de inteligencia
rusa que están en reconocimiento para
facilitar la entrada de las tropas rusas
en kiev y al centro neurálgico de la
capital
puede advertirse esos agentes pueden ser
abatidos es lo que dicen los ucranianos
puedo decirles que hace varios días hay
la persecución de estos agentes rusos
uno de nuestros colegas de rf y ruso fue
interpelado por las autoridades y estaba
haciendo un reportaje y lo detuvieron
las fuerzas del orden antes de que se
dieran cuenta que por supuesto era un
periodista con killzone con
determinación personal y este método de
la confusión porque era ruso creyeron
que era un agente ruso porque se parecía
a un hombre que estaban buscando ahora
es la búsqueda de estos paracaidistas
que están en reconocimiento en kiev que
provocan estos combates en las calles
equipos
esta noche fue muy difícil en que por
primera vez oímos en el centro tiros
ruidos y también detonaciones que
continúan la situación es muy volátil
muy complicada
de detonación de detonación
y por eso el alcalde endureció el toque
de queda para estar seguro de que las
únicas personas que están en las calles
después de las cinco de la tarde sean o
los militares o los rusos que están
percibiendo en general anders el fort en
jaque